[Music]
all right
joe don't even have his chair in front
of the camera joe looks like he's ready
to go
camping he's ready he's good or just end
up sleeping on the streets one or the
other whatever comes first
technically camping and sleeping on the
streets is more or less the same [ __ ]
yeah you know people be like you know
what's funny is people be like
i'm i'm a minimalist it's like [ __ ]
people been doing that [ __ ] it's called
being poor
right it's like i'm urban
i'm urban camping i'm van lifeing
it's like [ __ ] that's just being
homeless that's living out of your car
and living out of your car i'm gonna be
a minimalist
van life camper shut the [ __ ] up dude
but you know what is that what you want
to do yeah
exactly you know what though i would
have to say
that um it's it's proven to me that just
because you live out of a car
doesn't mean that you can't do it with
style
you could be see why people is just this
i'm homeless
with style that's all it is that's what
hipsters are yeah hipsters
homeless with style how would you style
up your
homeless people don't have style though
so you're saying homeless people have
styles i'm saying
it's assuming how many people don't
style i've seen some pretty stylish
homeless people
when you got three teeth and you're
walking around jacking off in public
i don't know that style we're not
talking about all homeless people
it's just a specific group but hey you
got style let's just focus on the the
facts here you got style
and you're not regular homeless you're
like homeless with style
homeless baller homeless jobless he's
jealous
yup speaking of camping though uh when's
the last time y'all went camping like a
week ago
a week ago about a week go get this
[ __ ] pun and [ __ ]
not the shoulder job i had the whole
chest out already too and he was like
you notice
this it's funny because it's already
exposed and i'm like exposing it again
yeah you got the joke thank you yeah
that's why it's funny
yes i think the last time i was when we
went shooting it was me joe and a couple
other people
oh that was like october dude damn it's
been like a year
we went you guys oh yeah
it was that's true yeah yeah i saw spin
just fly out
from who dude you said october with a
burp but
i did a [ __ ] spin just shot over i
missed it
oh [ __ ] look at joe i love sitting here
wait
why you asked the camping question
because i love camping because there is
a company now that will pay you a
thousand dollars to go camping for two
days
without internet i did that this weekend
you ho
me too like waiting for like this
freaking catch that's yeah with my
internet oh my god i'd do that for free
that was me
don't tell them i thought too don't tell
them that that's what camping's called
no internet are you supposed to do like
r d for their equipment or something
i'll do that too no i think it was just
a campaign for them to
to just get awareness up for their
further they just want to give money
away
that's what that sounds a thousand yeah
it's not much money by the way
it's called satellite internet it's the
name of the company i don't even know
wait they want you to camp
for two nights no internet for a
thousand dollars wants you to camp
without internet
yes that's like spectrum going don't use
our [ __ ]
we're addicting i think they're trying
to be mindful of
health like mental health or whatever so
it's like they want your
eye health maybe like get away so it's
kind of like when alcoholic where uh
alcoholic brands say drink responsibly
it's like don't drink too don't drink
too much of me
it's like when a surgeon general warning
is on a cigarette box that says smoking
kills and they show like a bunch of dead
people and stuff is it like that
yeah maybe that's but they do it much
more like in a healthy
like positive way it's like there's this
is the uh
application page well rv i love rv oh
it's and it's in an rv
yes easier what you get to do is a
thousand dollars in
credit for their services that's what it
says it's probably i'm guessing
so dates we'll choose the winner on
september 23rd
2020 and the candidate must have set by
september 30th but then you apply here
and what they want you to do is to
travel across the country in an rv
uh you get to pick the destination and
then you all you have to do is spend an
entire weekend
without your phone laptop well how are
we going to
document the journey and [ __ ] you get to
document it
ah that's that's a stupid-ass brand deal
i think so too
i think so too but it made me think
though let's do it even when we do go
camping
all right just and be realistic here
when we do go camping
do are we ever without technology nope
[ __ ] no
i want to take people don't have our
phone streaming music yeah we're
straight so it's like it's like
hey now take take our usual experiences
of camping
yes take that and then it depends on
what you define as technology because
flashlights could be technology
true true i think it's it's wi-fi based
technology no
there was no reception where i go that's
good so you see you totally blacked out
then
i have to take pictures i have to go pro
because
what's the point of doing this if i
can't show off to you guys gopro has
wi-fi capability
oh true true did you use the wi-fi
though did you use the wi-fi the
mountains didn't let me but you could
bring a mobile hotspot and then
go wi-fi we went camping last time i
brought her mobile hot spots
uh upload my really cool shooting videos
i did it not because i wanted to
i did it because i wasn't prepared so
next time i'll bring wi-fi honorable of
you to
put out there i just think this is easy
i think we should apply that's really
easy
i think they should extend the challenge
i think they should do like
a month or something or something yeah
something ridiculous but
i mean i don't know because like we
never really go camping and actually
completely black out you know
no i mean this past weekend we went to
the cabin and i
touched my phone maybe like two times
like that's not even camping
but like camp like kevin like you know
being in nature
not being at home like that's what i
consider like in that realm
unless you go all right guys i'm gonna
go take a [ __ ]
he did one pass here and then he went to
the dirt just wanna know his technique
he was wiping the ship you wiped the
[ __ ] onto the hole and then you put it
in the dirt onto the pile that's already
there yeah i just wanted to clarify
mine or did you have toilet paper i had
wet wipes that are biodegradable
so then when you're burying camping
that's wi-fi cheater
okay fine
next time i'll think about you when i'm
wiping my ass and i go wait
this isn't real camera no it's not i'm
gonna let tiff down
and i'll jump in the lake and then i'll
[ __ ] wipe my ass and then you just
say water and brush your teeth go to the
upstream though
make sure you're and that's true yeah
you know our friend peed in the lake
that we're grabbing water from
what like a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's right
he realized what he was doing at the
time
we all got mad at him right next to you
or like really far away no
on the other side thankfully okay so
like we were kind of like water or a
lake
we were like in a cul-de-sac he just had
to do it in the water
and then there was a waterfall coming
from this side and it was glacier water
so then it was it was good water and
then he peed on this side
so we had a cove he was on this side
yeah it's just dumb cause he didn't have
to do it in the water tree water
surprise
super inconsistent it's a guy too you
could pee anywhere you want
drank the water i used that water to
brush my teeth it tastes like
no i had to boil it though because i was
paranoid yeah because if it's lake in
like stagnant water it's running good
how'd you how did you boil it did you
have something oh we made a fire
fire and then they had pots and we just
put water in the pot and then we boiled
that water usually how you
boil water yeah that's true that's
[ __ ] funny
well i was thinking like did you have
like a gas stove or something i know
he's
like he didn't explain like the because
he obviously would all think that
he didn't explain like what the
mechanism was to start the fire or any
of that that's the thing what you really
wanted to know
is that usually when he gets water to a
certain place it boils
oh yeah yeah i didn't want to just
eat it i wanted to learn that dang it
you know they have a lot of different
ways to boil
water you know at night you're freezing
that's what he was asking oh
they have chemical packets oh yeah that
boil the water
like in the japanese uh the japanese
thingies the instant food
yeah cause like do you like break it and
put it in and it just boils
you add water and then there's a
chemical reaction well you can't drink
this water
right but it's to cook things oh so like
so like there's like
uh ready-made uh packets like chili
beans or soups or whatever that
backpackers use
yeah and then um if you just add water
to this bag
on the bottom it starts boiling like if
there's a chemical reaction and then you
can
you can take like it heats up whatever
that's a way to eat something
um they have the jetboils that's just
[ __ ] sick
it's a small little propane tank like
shabu-shabu style
but then like you have a cup like that
and it just immediately
high [ __ ] flame and it's last forever
yeah but we just did old school
we chopped trees oh how fun i brought an
axe
they chopped the trees did you get
blisters and [ __ ] no because i didn't do
chopping i made everyone else do it
i was the fireman you're the fireman
yeah i was a fireman
uh i brought i have actually
i want to show you something special
it's uh it's in my backpack
wait where's my back is it your flint
thing yeah i have a flint thing
i don't know where my backpack thing
what's the flint thing oh it
was like oh yeah oh yeah gravy with the
blade and it creates spawn immediately
starts fire yeah it makes it super easy
yeah it's like i have two of them and
then you go shh
like that and then i was like [ __ ] this
taking too long hey let me borrow your
lighter
and like and then once the fire was
started did you move walk out
no did you pee on the fire together i
actually love
[ __ ] with the fire so me and um my
buddy josh
we got rocks together like it was his
idea to build like this whole
rock thing and then he created like a
little
plate platform with this with the flat
slab and that's where we put like the
pots in
um what was the slab made out of rock
yeah it was just a big rock circle and
then the slab
was like kind of like our stove and then
under
we can still put like uh wood and all
that so it heats up the stone
that [ __ ] was pretty sick yeah yeah it
was really fun
and then and we had two guys just
chopping trees non-stop
we had dry wood and you can you can just
go after any tree
because i don't know oh yeah there's a
type of dry dry yes
in california almost every tree that's
dead
is dry as [ __ ] and there's no regulation
in california yes there is oh there is
regulation you don't put down trees that
are like up though if they're like
already down
right those ones usually break up
because they're gonna dry out anyway
they're not like moist inside depends on
the area but i think
oak is protected how can you tell you
just have to know trees you have to know
trees yeah
and then also uh anything under
10 000 feet you can't
uh do a wildfire like you can't just
like there's a gorilla camping right
like a lot of people just [ __ ] set up
um and and and you got to be extremely
careful because of how dry california
is uh so to start a forest fire yeah but
under 10 000 you can prevent forest fire
that's what the bear said yeah
so under 10 000 feet you don't want to
do it over i think it's fine
in most places you measure how high up
you are it says the elevation sign
everywhere you go
yeah and then so we were at like the
phone
brings a electric tape or whatever from
the ocean to the mountain
i ran out no because you know they have
like compass apps and stuff i'm like i
wonder
what elevation but no wi-fi though no
they like they have like altimeters
and like a watch and i'll tell you like
where you're at how much elevation
you're at see
i'm not done
you